[Musique]
ils vont éloigner encore céline d'office
c'est pas bon pour le coeur
l épave aux lettres j'ai cassé ma
grand-mère raison qu'avant merde tu fais
des conneries tu fais des casques avec
des scooters volés
tu vois ta rennes volley annan pour
entrer les personnes les jeunes
narbonnais ont fait pas je peux t'on été
longtemps je vais partir l'australie tu
vas comment licorne qui collaient aux
bagnoles tu vas apprendre à dire les
voitures les importe quoi et pas de sens
là pour mettre des pièces
la troisième j'ai ici quand j'ai besoin
de réfléchir je peux faire passer cheikh
seck c'est juste un grand tu rigoles
contre la bretagne enfin vous avez 40 de
mot pour parler de la pluie c'est toi
qui tombent les gars étaient déçus nous
embrouiller jeté un sérieux tu veux dire
bonjour c'est pour manger
oui la nourriture on va manger de la
nourriture solide arrêt car il n'arrive
même pas à savoir si s'il manque des
consonnes tous y en a trop c'est bien
qu'ils s'impliquent 4 vous seriez pas ça
ne change je ne saurais on aura avancé
tu rattrapera jamais le temps perdu tout
raté ta vie ton fils
c'est ce que tu penses aussi pas ton
fils
bernard emié les années 80 chouette la
musique médiévale